Hey, listener, it's Stefan. I'm here a little early from my episode. I think we're probably waiting for Jason to clean his golf shoes and get his equipment going, which is very They go off community, but nevertheless I'm here. This is smartness. Smartness. Smartness. Smartness. Smartness. Smartness. Smartness. Smartness.
Smartness. Smartness. Smartness. Smartness. Smartness. Smartness. Smartness. Smartness.
Smartness. Smartness. Listener, we had a record earlier this morning. Went very well, very fun. Nice. We had we had a today's a two for and we had a what a three hour break, something like that. Yeah, what you guys do. Well, took a nap. Well, did you really? I did take a nap. I did too. No, I took a little nap, not too long.
I watched obviously. No way. It took a little nap not too long. I watched obviously some some soccer stars and I'll get their first loss, huh? I did watch Arsenal get their first loss. So this dating this podcast, but I did watch that that match. It was very controversial. Was it? Yeah, there's a very controversial goal because they lost one meal and there was controversial goal. People are really mad at the the VAR, the video system referee. We don't need to put the audience into their own nap going over this. Sean, what'd you do? I did, I took a, I took a little nap. Just lunch before you nap.
I had a BLT. You did? Yeah. And a BLT with extra mail. Your food is always so special. You ever just have like normal shit? What's not normal about a BLT? You have to make the bacon and put it on the side. No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no Hey, can I guess what kind of bread it was on? White bread. White bread.
Country white. Will have you ever bought a loaf of white bread? I've always been the country of that. Sounds better. Will have you ever bought a loaf of white bread? Sure. Really? Have you ever, what is it?
But a loaf of white bread. Of course, what are you talking about? I don't know if I have, you have of course have. And I will say that the little kids, the little kids, they like white bread, but not, you know, they get a sort of, I don't know. It's children's food. That's all Sean eats. I eat white bread and drink milk almost every day.
What did you guys have? Jason, you and Amanda went over for dinner the other night. What did we have? What a beautiful, lovely dinner. Beautiful roasted chicken and roasted vegetables and a salad and then we had to hear about it the whole time. Scott and Sean were fucking furious. That's what they had to eat because we were there.
No, we knew you were coming over. So we made sure there was like, you know, Jason and Amanda food. And then for dessert, there is there is brownies. This is Jason Amanda versus Sean and Scotty. We had the brownies. They had chocolate covered dates. So listen, true. That's true. Well, first of all, you supplied them. Think I'm, we would enjoy them. And, but you didn't touch the brownie. Oh, I sure did. Touched it big. You did my mouth touched it. I will. I've seen Jay, you know, sometimes I can have it big. You did? My mouth touched it. I will.
I've seen Jay, you know, sometimes I can have Sunday night, somebody will bring a, usually you and Scotty and somebody else will bring a dessert. And I've seen Jason over, over, over shared. I have addiction issues, you know, but, but, but, but, um, Eli was asking me today about dinner and I don't know. Anyway, I said, he asked me Jason, what you, oh, we were talking about Atlanta. Uh-huh.
And I was saying he's like, well, what did he order in a lot when he was living up there in that building where we ended up? I said, no. No, I'm sleep by 7.30. He hold by 7.30, he'll have a little salad and some crackers. Well, dinner, yeah. True story.
Really? I said, the body is no fluke. This body right here, it doesn't just have it. But last night at dinner, Jason, last night at dinner, we were at a restaurant. I have a McCarthy salad, no bacon, sauce, dressing on the side. Dressing on the side, and then something else, no egg or something. Nope, nope. Just don't fucking mix it and give me the dressing.
Which dressing did you ask for for that? I know the place. What would you do? Yeah, it's just just a bullseye mixed dinner grid. Yeah, the thing. Yeah. Yeah, it's nice. It's real nice. Yeah, you don't want a heavy pour on the salad, you know, it just ruins all the vegetables. So I don't, I don't like a drinking salad dressing, yeah. Yeah. I don't think so doubt it. All right. Let's, let's, let's, now you want to talk about somebody who knows what to do with themselves. When it comes to taking care of themselves.
Yeah, I do. I got a guest for you. Hold on. I pull up my notes here. There's that and here's this. Here we come. Ready? Quiet.
Today we have someone who is equally successful in personal accomplishments as he is in teamwork. He is as rich as he is philanthropic. He is as famous as he is soft spoken. This man was the first to have been voted MVP unanimously in NBA history. He has nine NBA All-Star selections. He has four NBA championships, and he was the first player to hit 103 pointers in the NBA Finals. He is widely regarded as the greatest shooter in NBA history. He's not a bad golfer either, and he's our guest today, saying hello to Steph Curry. Shut, Steph. Yeah, front. Hello, sir. Door.
Okay. Is this a bookie? Is this a side door? Shut the back door? Shut it down. I can't believe this. Yes. And I'm married to Canadian.
Did you? I'm married to Canadian. And you spent a lot of time in Toronto. Yes, I do. Yes, I do. We're welcome to do. We're welcome to do. Steph, I'm very excited you're here today.
Thank you. So this is great, great to be here. Great to meet you. Yeah, really nice to meet you. Sean, you don't have to fake it. I didn't do it to myself later. Let's talk about that. It goes deeper.
The resonant. I am, of course, no, who you are. I'm very impressed with you in your life. Yeah, it's incredible. Now, are we recording this at three o'clock because you had to play golf this morning? I wish. So I had a really great golf season, I guess, in the summer. I think I saw you during the lakes passing by your neck of the woods. But come October when we start our season, the golf clubs develop some develops some cobbelabs pretty quick. You don't take them with you at all?
I try to, I play maybe twice a month if I'm lucky, but we are in beautiful Cleveland, Ohio right now. I'm sure between three games and four nights. So as a 35 year old, am I 15th year? Most of the time is dedicated to staying as you feel as possible. Now, what's the big key on that for you? What do you, what, what, what gets you, what do you try to avoid that gets you super duper tired?
What do you, what do you, what do you use in white, serious? I was laughing. I was talking about Sean's lunch. I was like, I wish I could have had that. That's right. Right. Yeah. We know each other. Sean, Sean, Sean, Sean, Sean, your cookie that. That's right. Right? Yeah. We know each other.
Sean, Sean, Sean, Sean, your cookie pouch. This is what Steph's trying to avoid. It's the cookie. There it is. But you know what, I bet when you're 53, when you're 53, you might have one. I might have one. Yeah, so watch out. Something to look forward to.
Yeah. Did your dad ever get himself a cookie pouch after he stopped playing? He did. And, uh, so he played 16 years in the NBA. He did? He did. He played, uh, he played, you know, drafted in 86 by Utah Cleveland and he spent 10 years in Charlotte, which is where I grew up, my family.
And then he ended up his last three years in Toronto, which is, uh, I lived there for three years. I can't wait for my obvious question. Just, yeah, I did it. Does that mean you wanted to do it or was it forced upon you? which is I lived there for three years. I can't wait for my obvious question. Yeah, I did it. Does that mean you wanted to do it or was it forced upon you? It was a little bit of both.
It's kind of forced upon you just by, that's all you're in. You're in a gym all the time. You're following him and it's, you develop a love for it. But I played all the sports growing up, baseball, football, obviously golf too. But so you loved it.
You loved sports. I loved it. Yeah. And I got to see most of his career, which was cool. Because I was born his third year in the league. And so he retired when I was 12. And sorry, when I was 13 when I was in Toronto. But when he retired, he definitely working out was not
a priority for a while. And then when I, he got, he got an inspire when, actually, when I got married back in 2011, that was the, that was the emphasis for him to get back in shape. He didn't want to walk down the aisle with, right, we even went the footer to the other side. But you know, it's, you know,
it's, it's, let me ask you this, how long would a guy last in the NBA for all the eight was salad and nuts? You know what straight up? Oh, I'd say that guy, I'm the smallest guy usually out there. I'd be able to back that guy down in the post. If he was a Saladin nut, that's a hard time finding him. Exactly.
Is there the vegan lifestyle that's taken over the league? Really? Really? Yeah. Honestly, I don't touch it. I don't know how they get their calories in. Is there the vegan lifestyle is taking over the league really really really yeah I honestly I don't touch it. I don't know how they get their their calories in I know there's a science behind it, but one of my teammates Chris Paul now who's Been thinking vegan for about four years. Yeah, I just I'm fascinated by what he brings on the plane or at meal time You know what what what, how it gets his nourishment. I'm just amazed. I just stare at him. I feel like I'm an awkward like, you know, a social bad. I'm just staring at everything you say, asking questions like, how, how.
Now you, you mentioned all those sports that you played growing. Are there any sports that you're, that you're not great at? Like just terrible at? Uh, I've picked up a lacrosse stick once and just had a good neck for figuring out how to do that. Anything really soccer, I guess you could say I don't have any of these last year going on, but I'm athletic so I could get by, I think. You could fake it. There's a lot of similarities to basketball and soccer with the movement and it's a lot
of tennis ball movement. How's your tennis game? Tennis to solid. It's getting stronger. Yeah, cool. See? Come on. How's your tennis game? It's tennis a solid. It's getting stronger. Yeah, cool. See? Come on.
You know what, Ashley, we just had, we had our buddy, John McNeer on the podcast not long ago. And we talked about the idea of kids when they're young. He was, he's such a big proponent of, kids should not just play one sport. He's like, you should play multiple sports. That's really important. And it sounds like you did that. I prescribed that for sure. There's so many, you know, cross-over skill sets and, you know,
personalities that you interact with, the demands on your body, your mind, especially for , you know, younger kids that kind of get exposed. To be able to figure out like what comes naturally, what doesn't and how can you kind of close that gap. So yeah, I didn't pick basketball till I was 13 as my only sport. And even then I was still playing golf on the side and had some other curiosity. But that was when it came solely focused. Wow. That's cool. I played basketball and before high school and you in great school. I need some footage. I need to say. I don't think you talk about the difference for grade school. I need some footage. I need to say. Yeah, I don't. I don't think. I don't think you talk about the difference for it.
The experiences, I need some footage. I will do some footage. I remember the coach saying, give it to Hayes because I never got the ball. And give it to Hayes. He was screaming, give it to Hayes. And I would run down all the teammates with separate. Just give me one shot, like every 10 games.
Aless. I'm just waiting. You got to participate in trophy for sure. just give me one shot like every 10 games. The less. You got a participation trophy for sure. It's like, it's like, it's like, you can go see where they do that, where they get like the towel get it and they bring it in and they let them. Um, so it's true. Hey, so Steph, was there any any significant challenges right at the beginning
to to playing basketball? Probably not, right? I mean, you learned early, get get your shooting technique. I'm sure your dad like helped you. Was there like your height? You weren't you weren't small. You were kept getting bigger. What do you what'd you top out at? How tall are you? kept getting bigger. What do you top out at? How tall are you? I'm six three right now, but I was five, seven, and about a hundred and forty,
five pounds my freshman year in high school. Wow. Wow. It was a picture of me and my varsity team like sitting up front, you know, cross-legged and just like, who, yeah. You could have,
how we just described Sean playing basketball, you probably, if you didn't know who I was, you look at the picture, you're like, oh, that's that case. So then with your dad starting to condition you for like, it's probably not going to happen. If you will see how tall you get, but if you don't get to X, start thinking about other things.
Yeah, that was, I mean, to the other question about was a force. I mean, that was, I'm so grateful for how my parents approached introducing me to the game because obviously you have a dad at play 16 years, there's kind of an understanding of basketball as in this future. But the physicality, the efficiencies I had early, and you know, there was always just an encouragement to just work, figure it out, build confidence as you go without really thinking about what the results were.
Like, obviously I knew what the NBA was. I knew what Division 1 basketball was. I knew that that was a good way to try to get a scholarship to a good school. But everything that they taught me and the coaches that I had kept me really in the moment, which is something I try to teach kids now, because there's such a pressure on, you know, sports aside,
that doesn't matter what you're talking about. There's such a pressure to fast forward the process and the journey of how you get there because you see the polished product forced on you every time you open up your phone. And so me shooting, three's in the final and just go over coming all day adversity I had in my career.
It's all just that snapshot. But if you rewind the clock back and you talk to me when I was a sophomore in high school, the NBA was such a distant idea. I was really enjoying playing basketball and being in that environment. But was it really, considering your lineage, right? Your father, I would imagine you had all the added pressure of, if I am lucky enough to get in,
am I gonna be as good? And like, how did you deal with that because you over indexed there? But not only that Jason, think about this too. Did you have the thing where you had, you must have known, you had good hand-eye coordination, you played golf, you played a lot of different sports, you knew that you were athletic.
And so you you must have had an inkling that like, Hey, if I can bring this stuff together, if I can land this plane, I'm going to do some outside of the pressure. But if you do, but if you don't, there's that, that's going to be embarrassing for you for them for like, how did you deal with all that? Yeah, it is a nice balance in my parents. I guess inherently they both embodied it on the daily. My dad played 16 years, my mom was a founder of a Montesori school that I went to in elementary school. So it was kind of like a good balance of priorities.
If I start talking about like, I missed my first middle school game because I didn't do the dishes. They had my chores. This is like a written, it's like my house. So like the strictness that came with the priorities, like I was here to make sure you had good grades, make sure you took care of yourself in the classroom,
took care of your family and things at home. And then sports was down the way. They didn't let a slot on any of that. So I think it gave us a perspective of, you know, sports is fun. And this is something that is in our family. It's in our blood. Yeah. But there was always perspective.
But to the point of, yeah, I knew I was talented and gifted in certain areas, but it didn't really match up to the feedback I was getting from coaches and recruiters, especially when I got to high school, cause I grew up in Charlotte. My dad played 10, 11 of his 16 years there. So when you del Curry's son in Charlotte, like people know who you are. So there is that added pressure.
Anytime you step foot in the gym, they have an expectation of who you're supposed to be. But I didn't really have to, that wasn't the conversation at home, so I kind of could get away from it, if that makes sense. It was nice, it was a nice healthy balance there. Were you playing, did you play at school, you obviously went to school in Toronto or in your school?
Yeah, Queensway Christian College, it doesn't exist anymore, but it was in Atobaco, wow, Ontario, yeah. I know Atobaco, wow. All right, you know what's from Atobaco? Is is Shanny Brandon Shanahan who's a friend of ours who runs the Toronto Maple is good friend of the program. Friend of mine. I'm kind of a mentor to him. And that's great. That's make I just give him a lot of guidance. He goes on and on about it. It's crazy. Now, Steph, what's your feeling on this? You know, I was at the Laker game the other night
and you know, they do a great job there with them for the crowd and everything with the music and all that. But I'll be happy to hear that you approve. I realize, well, I'm saying something nice before I say something shitty. They're, you know, they got music going every single time the Lakers take the ball down the court. And I started thinking, well, I wonder if the Lakers are pissed off about this. They're hearing this distracting. It's basically they're scoring this movie, you know, with music. That's a new thing, isn't it?
Didn't it used to be kind of like quiet and then they play music if something good happens? Now, honey, here's to other. This is part of our experience. We hear it, but it doesn't really bother effect us. Kobe Bryant used to say, I guess there was a conversation in yeah where he talked about him working out in the summer. He used to have a dead silent because that's what he wanted to impart on
like the home crowd. That was like the feeling he wanted a dead silence and here's something to work out that way. I'm not that maniacal in terms of like, you know, process, but when you're out there in the court, you hear the music, the atmosphere, you hear the fans cheering at you, all that type of stuff. The funny part is I've been a part of one unique game
in New York, Madison Square Garden. I think it was 2017. They tried like the old school method where there was just there was no PA announcer there was no in arena music at all no atmosphere was just the crowd noise was like taking it back to the nineteen forty-fifth years whatever yeah it was the worst experience really like you just hear the shoes squeaking yeah people clear their voices and drop the cups and stuff.
They abandoned it at halftime. They said, this is not working. Let's go back to that. That's terrible. Halftime. Anyway, we, everybody was complaining. So Steph, you know how in golf, there's like, there's thing called swing thoughts, right? We have like this one thing you think about and it gets your whole swing all in a groove,
right? Like just like tuck the right elbow in or, you know or right finger on the shit, whatever the hell it is. Do you have a swing thought that has consistently worked for you in shooting the basketball? Like do you think back of the rim or front of the rim or bottom of the net that puts it in a certain arc that you can count on that has worked for you over the years? Yeah, I think the biggest, it's a thought
and a feeling all at the same time, but if I'm in balance, and that can mean a lot of different things, I can be moving right, left, forward, backward, one foot, right, two feet, whatever it is, but there's a feeling of balance that, you know, no matter how many times I've been in the gym, shooting any type of shot or envision, you know,
a game kind of unfolding with your mental process and all that, like I can feel when I'm in balance and when I'm in balance, I feel like I'm never going to miss. And so you don't think too hard about it. Like, no, you try to keep it really simple. The muscle memory and mechanics take over. But all I'm thinking about right before I shoot is, can I get into proper balance and then from there? It is something I noticed so clearly about you,
is such a unique quality of yours that you always seem to be so at ease and graceful and calm with everything that you do. Yes, you're explosive and you're fast when you need to. But for the most part, what I sort of take away is that there's just a calmness and an ease to everything that you do that I bet every player wish they had. Well, I'll add to that.
I've had the same thing because sometimes you're watching you in so many different situations. And obviously you're a competitor and you see guys get some guys get really heated, whatever. You stay very calm. You seem very present in the moment. Is that something that you work on? Oh, for sure. That's what he was like. What's the question? Coming out of the joy. That's where the joy comes from. So there's a calmness to it, but I'm a little kid out there on the
court even, you know, 15 years in. If I ever lose that, then I know it'll be time to quit because the presence and the mindfulness of what's happening right now and literally I get lost in the game. So the work or the business of basketball creeps in from time to time because there's so much that goes on in terms of putting the team together and the ups and downs of an 82 game schedule or the pressures of performing every single night. But honestly, when I step foot on the floor, it's just pure joy. And that's where I live. We'll be right back.
Thank you to Rocket Money for their support. Did you know over 80% of people We'll be right back. That's why Rocket Money is here. Rocket Money is a personal finance app that finds and cancels your unwanted subscriptions. Monitor's your spending and helps lower your bills all in one place. With Rocket Money, you can easily cancel the ones you don't want with just the press of a button. No more long hold times or annoying emails with customer service. Rocket Money does all the work for you. Rocket Money can even negotiate to lower your bills for you by up to 20%. All you have to do is take a picture of your bill and rocket money takes care of the rest. Rocket money also lets you monitor all your expenses in one place.
Recommends custom budgets based on your past spending and they'll even send you notifications when you've reached your spending limits. With over 5 million users in counting, rocket money has helped save its customers an average of $720 a year and $1 billion in total saving so far. Stop wasting money on things you don't use. Cancel your unwanted subscriptions and manage your money the easy way by going to rocketmoney.com slash smartless. That's rocketmoney.com slash smartless. Rocketmoney.com slash smartless.
at money.com slash smartless rocket money.com slash smartless. A big thank you to our friends at Macy's for sponsoring this episode of the pod cast. From now until Saturday, November 25, Macy's online Black Friday event is saving you big on the essentials and gifts you've been waiting to snatch up all year. From appliances, hello, stand mixer, and cookware to bedding and self-care staples, you'll find great prices for the picks you need in every room.
Plus, shop specials on the latest clothing trends, designer handbags, jewelry, and your fave beauty brands. And chip away your gift list with big savings on gifts like watches and wireless headphones. Don't forget super fun toys. Cozy Winter Gear and more unique finds that the kids in your life will be excited to get. Plus, get free shipping when you spend $25.
So visit Macy's in store or check out Macy's.com before November 25th. That's Macy's.com before November 25th. That's Macy's.com. Some exclusions apply. Check out Macy's.com for details. SmartLess is sponsored by ADT. Now ADT professionally installs Google Nest products, so your home is safe and smart.
You can check in on your home and manage your security system from virtually anywhere. With Nest Cam's and the Nest Doorbell, you can even get intelligent alerts so you receive notifications on what matters most. Google Nest Cam's can tell the difference between a person, an animal, a vehicle, or with the Nest Doorbell even a package. I mean, guys, technology, what? And with Nest aware, as part of your monthly ADT service, you get 30 days of event, video, history, and even smarter notifications like when a familiar or unfamiliar face is seen.
I like that. I think that you like it too. Plus, when every second counts, you can trust ADT's 24-7 professional monitoring. You can view video of an alarm event and verify or cancel an alarm with just a tap. When the most trusted name in home security adds the intelligence of Google, you know what you got? You got a home with no worries. Go to ADT.com today or call 1-800-ADT-ASAP. Google, Nest Cam, Nest Doorbell, and Nest Aware are trademarks of Google LLC. All right, back to the show.
My two questions that I have to ask is, one of the time, please. No, I was waiting for the two-parter, because I know how this goes. It goes. Oh, yeah. The worst. Because the guy to get them in.
I gotta get these in. Worst fight you've ever had on the court and worst injury. Oh, great, great. Worst fight. Anyway ever had on the court and worst injury. Oh, great, great. Worst fight. Anyway, we're gotten a beat down from you? No, I've gotten a beat down. It was in, I think it's on YouTube, so it was in Indiana in 2013.
Roy Hibbert, David West. Oh, yeah. And my teammate at the time, David Lee, Roy Hibbert and David Lee kind of squared up on the way at the basket. And it was like big man on big man crime. Guards and little guys stay out the way. Like that's kind of a known thing in the league
when the big guys are going at it. There's everything else around, doesn't matter. My dumbass wanted to get in there and, you know, protect my teammate. So they square up, they chest bump, and I run up behind Roy Hebert. He's seven foot, probably two hundred and ninety two and eighty pounds. And I try to grab him from the back and like pull him off my teammate. And when I tell you, it was like, swatting the fly off,
he literally just took his left hand and just, and I went, it was literally under the basket. I flew all the way to the corner, like, feed off, land slid across the court. So now I'm embarrassed, I have to like get up and act like I'm coming back for more. And that's when David West, he was like the big punisher, the enforcer on the court.
And he like kind of chest hit, you know, stiff arms me and pushing me to my place and like just holds me one hand. And it's all this commotion on him. And later the story is, I would have gone for it that he just held me back. Yeah, I was gonna go for you. He say by the way Roy Hibbert nice guy. Very guy. Got a mean look got a mean left left swimmer. He's got a mean. He's got left spot. He calls it. He's got a mean left. I never knew how strong will was until we were doing our, and I, I had no idea you were. I'm not taking my shirt off, dude. No, but he really, like, so.
He's, it's so, he's so in assuming I tried to push him with all of my body weight. I couldn't push him an inch. Yeah, it's, it's annoying. All right. Yeah. I will ask you this. Do you, do you apply that same kind of approach and you talk about the balance and being present when you do all, all, other sportly like when you play golf or do you have because some people and I'm not going to name names
some people when they stand over the ball, they stand there like a psycho and they might be up to 30 seconds like a frickin psycho. Like you think this guy I'm glad he's over the ball because otherwise he's going to be out. You know, I check this is like much shorter now. It is. I heard you're working on it, right? I know.
He is working on his process. You've heard about the process. Yeah. So would you say, but do you, do you do that? Or do you just, you like just swing athletically and just do it? And the athletic tendencies take over. I am as maniacal about the game of golf Jason is just in terms of like I know there's always something to work on and get better and there's I'm creative in that mindset where you know
Every little detail kind of matters and I have to really try to turn all those thoughts off because they will get the best of you Especially I playing, I mean, selfishly been playing the best golf of my life and so it's like, how good can I really get? Yeah. This summer you run fire. You're a scratch, aren't you? I got to the other side of that. I'm like a plus two right now, which is, and how old do you, you're 35?
35, okay, so you have 15 years before the Champions Tour if you want it. If you want it, so 15 more years of training, you could be unstoppable on the champions tour. If you want to do that at 50, right, you can make that decision. That is a goal for sure. I know there's a, in the golf world, there's a lot of, you know, the arts celebrity and pro-AM stuff. And so you can scratch the competitive itch here and there, especially when I get the nine months of my basketball season back when it's all said none.
But yeah, champions tour, I mean, I'm sick. Like basketball could be on, I might have that on my phone, but on TV, it's golf channel. It's just a problem. Yeah, you owe me both. My wife thinks I'm such an idiot. Well, you know that the other night, a lot of apologies. Jason was over and I showed him my golf channel, which was this old house on PBS. I still watch this old house.
Do you know, you know that, Sean? I sure that. Oh, it's like, it's like from the 1970s, it's still on it. They do, they build homes, they build houses. Oh, yeah. Yeah, it's, it's, it's really, you know, who likes it? People are in commas. They play just to have so that they know that there's or people that just can't, they
can't roll a TV into a room if something's going to come up and they can't find their remote control. Those are the further what love. Yeah. If the remote is broken, they're out of the room. Yeah. Oh, they're strapped to a chair and it's stuck on PBS. It's the best show that they'll have. I said Jason, a video this morning, Jason's game has gotten so good. In my days, I don't have it.'t have it been playing as much but he's not a plus, but your game's good. I sent him this video today of this dude who played 18 holes with a five iron this morning. And only one to do was break 80 and he shot what is shooting 76? He shot 78. Yeah, what with a five iron? Yeah, he plays on the, he plays on the DP tour at European guy.
He did. That tells you how good those guys are. Yeah, he's two bunk, he's hit two green side bunkers shots, flop shots with a five iron dude. Yeah, it was crazy. We'll send it to you. Talk to me about you and Clay Thompson, the splash brothers, how did you develop the chemistry with him?
Is that, is that, you know, when anyone's ever asked me about chemistry with an actor or something like that, that it, I always say, well, it's not something you wore. It's just, that person's just nice. It's just, it's easy. If someone's not a prick, you can get along with them and you have chemistry immediately. Is that as simple as it is with you with life? Yes, transfer what it is to our relationship for sure.
Like we've been together on the court now for 12 years. And then you add Dreymon green to that for 11. So it's insane to think that two guys who've had dads that played in the NBA as well. That's what I was going to say. And like you said, have a good perspective about what we worked for to get here and you know, approach life very similarly with appreciation and gratitude that we kind of hit it off in the jump. And I don't know like when you get into these type of friendships and you know, from your standpoint with your, your people in the same profession,
you know, comments, whatever actors that you kind of sharpen each other's skillsets just about being around each other. And that's how we've been this entire time. It's not something that we actually like really talk about. It's like, you know, we don't come in and sit down at dinner. I would pretend like you're trying to shoot this year. What's your elbow at 90 degrees? But it's more just than we're in that environment. Our work ethics are pretty, you know, top knives in terms of, you know,
being able to try to figure out how to get better every single year. And that iron sharpen's iron is real. And there's such a respect level for the way that he approaches basketball and life. And that's why we're still doing it. And I'll bet the two of you with that kind of harmony and kindness and quiet leadership and all that stuff, it's infectious in the team, correct? Like you guys, I bet, have created a culture over there that it should be no surprise that you guys have
one that extra 10 to 15 games each year, whatever it takes to get to a place where you're in the finals. And once you're in the finals, that kind of harmony and a team environment really yields the extra thing that you need to be excellent as opposed to great. Yes? For sure. The culture part of a lot of different ways to lead, right?
There's a lot of different ways. You can be the loud one that needs to say something about everything. You can be the lead by example type. You can be the ones that show up when the lights are brightest and galvanize that confidence within the team. But following Steve Kerr, our coach, and the legendary coaches that he played for Phil Jackson, Greg Popovich played alongside Michael Kerr.
And it's been famously a really, really nice guy. Yeah. He's just a great manager of people, like an impersonable guy. He seems to have a very sort of similar disposition. Obviously, very different personality, but different disposition to Greg Popovich, both of whom I don't know at all. But it just seems like they have a very similar kind of vibe.
Is that right? Estrate shooters, they have a great sense kind of vibe. Is that right? It's straight shooters. They have a great sense of humor. Yeah. They have a perspective that our problems in the NBA and they're real. Like we're trying to win at the highest level. There's this pressure.
This is a multi-billion dollar industry that is set up to test you in all different ways. And if you want to win at the highest level, it's going to demand a lot from you. set up to test you in all different ways. And if you want to win at the highest levels, it's gonna demand a lot from you. But, you know, he has a great way of kind of explaining, like, we're blessed, man, we get to play basketball for a living and he reminds us to that every single day
when we come in. And that kind of just levels of playing field. He's level of trust within each other. And he does the best job of, when you come into a team kind of element. I don't care if it's sports, it's whatever fast of the life. Everybody has a specific role to play and he makes sure that that's clear, but it doesn't diminish your value to the success of the group.
I think he has a great way of managing that process of from day one to the end, making guys believe in that and that's why we've been able to sustain this level of success for a long time. But what do you guys do season to season? I've often wondered, like, you come in, you win a few championships, and so you're the best, you guys are the best, you've got an unbelievable team, you got great chemistry. What does it got like Steve Kerr say when you come in to camp whatever that is August, September to get ready for the new season? Do guys like him go, okay, well, we won last year, this year our approach is going to be because obviously the goal, like if he sat down and goes, we want to win a championship, like, yeah, no shit. Everyone's the one to win a championship. Does he, do they set different goals? They go, this is, this is what we're
going to do this year. Our approach is going to be different. Like, yeah, there's a way. I talked about what's happening right now. Like we've won four championships since 2015. We've been in six finals. So we've lost two of them. We lost in the second round last year to the Lakers. On a down year for us, which is that's how the high standard we've set.
Yeah, came into this year. And to your point,, obviously everybody knows if we don't win a championship, then it's a failed season for us because of the standard. Cool. You can't just come in and say that like there has to be a level of detail of how you're prosaier. For us, it's, we have to win the week. That's what we call it. So however many games there are that week, it gives you a singular focus on what do you need to do
to win the week. We need to have a winning record every week. And that's how you get the little bite size motivation for a nine month journey that there are so many emotional roller coaster rides throughout the year. And I think everybody, you want those little bit of celebratory moments, right? Whether you know you're gonna hit us, hit some down,
some tough parts of the season, some tough stretches, but all you go two in one and a three game week, and everybody's like, yeah, we did that. Like for Insingin' this one for a championship that might sound weird, but it's real because it keeps you in the fight. And that was the way he came in for this year. For somebody who doesn't watch sports, basketball, nothing, but they're constantly striving
to be the best that they can be and be excellent as much as they can. And that they might struggle sometimes with the moment when it's time to go to hit the shot, land the plane. What would you tell without getting too woo-woo, but is there something that you can say to the listener for them to maybe focus on that might get them centered and focus so that they've
got their best chance at being the best part of themselves. Like, do you, do you focus on anything that's kind of evergreen? Don't fuck up. I think that one was good. That's a great bumper sticker. We need to write. We need to write. Nike was going to do that one originally. Before just do it, they was taking it was going to be don't fuck up. Here's interesting because I guess I mean, like you say, you know, I sound too cliche with it, but it's literally like confidence is built off your preparation. And that's first and foremost. And if you can't let yourself in the mirror and say you did everything that you knew and within your control to put yourself in position to be prepared for whatever that moment is, then you're already behind the eight ball.
But then at that point, for me, the biggest hurdle that I had to overcome was like the legit fear of failure. It was legit. Like sometimes wanting to hide from the backlash or the criticism or the negative energy that you'll get if you don't accomplish whatever you set it up to do.
And once you go through that and put yourself out there, you realize it's not all that bad because that's kind of what life is about, right? I'm gonna do woo woo for just one second because to that point, I always say the greatest safety net in anybody's life is the fact that you're loved, right? So if you know you are loved
and you feel you're loved by your husband, your wife, your kids, your family, your friends, your teachers, your whoever, your coach, you are loved. So if you are loved, you can fail a million times and still have that love to fall back on. They'll be there to catch you. That's the challenge, too, they're probably, yeah.
Make sure you have that sort of... All the orphans. All the orphans just got the feeling's heard. I'm gonna go fucking dick. You never think about the orphans. You fucking dick. You fucking dick. You fucking dick.
You fucking... You fucking... I think focusing on all jokes aside, I have, and I can say what, especially in the profession that we're in, Jason started younger and so, but he also knows what it's like. I mean, I failed so much that I can't, all I did was fail for years. I didn't make, listen, we're all nodding, we're all nodding. Yeah, I know, we all are nodding because it's true. And I continue to do it. And I failed from the time I moved to New York, I was 20, I didn all notting. Yeah, I know. We all are notting because it's true. And I continue to do it. And I failed from the time I moved to New York.
I was 20. I didn't make it. I was so broke. And I just didn't. And I failed all the frickin' time. And then there's that turning point I was talking to my buddy Eli about it, that turning point where, you know, whatever, it's just plays. You start to get better at it.
You start to get better at it. You start to get better. And then you also, I think you develop a, I don't know, it's like an armor, like your skin gets thicker and you start just going like, you don't think about the failures. For me, my own thing is like, I kind of think about the stuff that's working,
because I think as humans, we just naturally, we can, we can have 95% of our life is working great and some 5% shit is bothering us and we will think about that 5% and that's raising us right. And so I had to do, I had to do so much sort of spiritual calisthenics to get to the place where I'm like, just think about what's working and focus on that. And I think that I got better at it, but fuck it took a lot of feeling out there.
And that comparison is the thief of joy thing, especially for us when you're looking around and you see people who are different on different timelines within their journey, right? Like, who knows what they've been through, what they've exposed, and has positioned them to that place. Or, you know, when you have those blinders on,
so the, whatever, like the journey, like the things that you learn through that failure, obviously we all know are key as long as you can make them useful and make them resources for the next step and not to tell you from whatever you put in your set not to do, but that journey, when you look back and to your point, I love that. The 95 to 5% thing is a real,
real, I'm putting that in perspective of everything that I've gone through because it's the shared goals that you have with those people around you, orphans aside that are extremely, I guess the most memorable parts of life. I'm not walking in looking at trophies, like my rings. It's nice to have them. Don't get me wrong. Nice to pull them out, but those represent the not much journey I was talking about with what Coach said. How many weeks did we win that year? And just the little bite sized things that make a difference in terms of your happiness and your peace of mind and the joy that you bring to it.
So for us, that's a big part of dumbing down the pressure that you're in on a daily basis. And Sean, touch on the love from family. And you've been, it's hard to miss if anybody's followed you through your career, how present your family is, with your parents, your kid, your wife, whatever. They seem to be omnipresent, that wife, whatever, they're always, if they seem to be army,
present, that seems to be obviously a key to success. And how awesome is it that you can share this with your parents? Obviously, seemingly a lot. Oh, for sure. And even, you know, family structures and things change and you start to, as it even us in the dough, that we get real deep with it. But like my parents got divorced a couple of years ago and it's like
the way that life kind of forces you to rethink and reimagine all your relationships and the growth that happens through that. It's a real blessing and through some tragedy and through some trauma, right? And even when you're in those moments, you kind of don't see it. But I think the maturity that comes, you know, through all those experiences you go through is the appreciation of who's pouring into your life on a daily basis, who's, you know, giving you a sense of confidence in who you are as a person and the value that you bring. And the more that you can put yourselves in those environments and my family has been a huge
support and stars all across the board and that in that respect I've now in the charge of passing on to my family and my kids and that's that's the beauty of Life right there. Yeah It sounds like you know no pain no gain, you know This is a phrase that I just thought up the other day that I was using quite a bit. I'm gonna write that down in the screen. I'm gonna write that down in the screen. I want to know the injury thing. We are worst injury. No pain, no gain.
I had, I've had, what, four surgeries in my NBA career. No way. Yeah. I had two early, my career, I had two ankle reconstructions. No. That were pretty nasty. I had two early, my career had two ankle reconstructions that were pretty nasty. And then I was just four years ago, I broke my hand, a big seven footer decided
he wanted to take a charge while I was in the air instead of, you know, meeting me at the rim and trying to block a shot. And I fell over top of him and he landed back on my hand. So I have two beautiful scars on my left hand. I broke a hand. I had a carpal tunnel syndrome relief surgery on it. I'm a tax feeling.
Just came back from texting him from... Sean got carpal tunnel doing a musical. We're in the same boat. We're in the same boat. Yeah, same. Add it to the resume. 82 games a year. 300 years. Are your fans know that all the things that you go through to put yourself in the same boat. I'm in the same boat. Yeah. Same. Add it to the resume. 82 games a year.
300 J. Fans know that all the things that you go through to put yourself in a position. I sing those for the performance. He did, by the way, that every night he had the ice before and after because he had to play and do eight shows. It was pretty crazy. I was piano injuries. Yeah. That's real. We all go through it. We all go through it. We'll be right back. Smartless is brought to you in part by Helix. Okay.
All the kids are on Helix mattresses and it's been an unbelievable success. And you know how I know? Because they all sleep really well. You know the deal if you've got kids if your kids aren't sleeping well It's an issue all the kids sleep amazing and it's been Since they got Helix matches. I don't know if I can draw a straight line to it But it's pretty if I were detective I'd be like the evidence is clear
Guess what? Oh, sorry, I was just waiting for you to guess. Okay, well, Helix, they've got an awesome Black Friday sale. So keep listening to hear the offer. But let me back up a little and tell you about the Helix lineup. They offer 20 unique mattresses, including the award-winning Luxe collection, the newly released Helix Elite collection, a mattress designed for big and tall sleepers,
and even a mattress, like I said, made just for kids. So, how will you know which Helix mattress works best for you and your body? Take the Helix sleep quiz and find your perfect mattress in under two minutes. Have you got two minutes to change your life? And your personalized mattress is shipped straight to your door. Free of charge, Helix is offering 25% off all mattress orders and a free bedroom bundle for our listeners in honor of Black Friday.
The bundle includes two free pillows, as well as a set of sheets and even a mattress protector. Go to helix.com slash smartless and use code Helix partner 25. This is their best offer yet and it won't last long with helix better sleep starts now. Smartless listener, this episode is brought to you in part by FanDuel.
Score early this NFL season with FanDuel America's number one sportsbook. Right now, new customers get $150 in bonus bets with any winning $5 money like bet. That's $150 if your team wins. And if you've been thinking about joining FanDuel, there's no better time to get in on the action. The app is so easy to use. There's a wide range of betting options, including spreads and player props,
overunders and just more, right? So, you know, I've always betting how long it's gonna take Jason. I wish there was a way that I could bet on how long it's gonna take Jason to hit his next shot on the golf course. Because right now, right now we right now,
we're looking at about 90 seconds to almost two minutes. And if we could start, if we could start dishing out odds on that, we honestly, that would be a good business. It would be incredible. I think I could make a lot of money. Anyway, I wish it was the thing. It's not, but if somebody could figure it out,
please let us know, or at least let Fandall know. So visit fandall.com slash smartless and kick off the NFL season, Fandall, official partner of the NFL, 21 plus exclusion supply, C-Show notes for full disclaimer. Hey smartless fans, have you heard you can listen to episodes of this very show Add Free
and one week early on Amazon Music with your prime membership? That's right, all your favorite smartless episodes can be heard Add Free anytime on Amazon Music, and you'll always be the first one to catch our new episodes so you can brag to your friends. But that's not all, you can listen to your other favorite shows like, I don't know, Bad Dates and Just Jack and Will. Early and ad-free too. They also have favorites like the daily part in my take. And up first, Amazon Music offers the most ad-free top podcast so we know they definitely have something
for you. And it's already included in your prime membership. To listen now, all you need to do is go to Amazon.com-smartless. That's Amazon.com-smartless or download the Amazon Music app. It's just.com slash smartless or download the Amazon music app. It's just that easy. And now back to the show. Steph, can you speak a little bit to the extent the league allows you to criticize this
in turn of in season tournament? Do you have any any comments? So this is not because I get paid by the NBA. I absolutely love it. Yeah. I'm hearing it's almost unanimous that you guys are all digging this. I'm still what it is brand new and so it's like soccer. They do it in soccer.
I love it. Right. We're playing the same. That's the biggest thing. The difference obviously. We're playing the same teams. It's all 30 of us just mixed up in different groups. Then we normally are in our divisions.
But what they did with the entertainment value and like, we played last night, first of all. Explain it to Sean. Explain it to Sean. Okay, so Sean, there's 30 teams in the NBA. Yeah. And we're all already separated into six divisions, five teams in each division.
Yeah, sure. So that's been the way it's been for 30 years now. What they did this year was they took each, they were the 30 teams and put you in six different groups within the Western Conversors, three groups in the Eastern Conversors, three groups. And they designated four regular season games within those groups.
So we play these teams anyway, but they designated these specific groups to say, this counts towards the end season tournament grouping. And so we played Oklahoma City last night and we won. So we're 1-0 in our group. We'll play Oklahoma City again, but that game won't be designated as the end season tournament game.
So there's still playing the regular season and the game they played last night against Oklahoma that still counts in the whole regular season. They still counts to the standings and counts to also counts towards this in season. Oh, that's crazy.
Is it a way for them to sort of like keep the middle the season exciting for the viewers? Yeah, it's for the viewers. And it just brings a fresh energy to our first, you know, 20 games up basically up until Christmas when it is kind of working Vegas for the people. So that's where it builds up to.
So after you play those four games in your group, the best team, or the team with the best record in each group, which would be 16s. And then there's two wild car spots, one for the West, one for the East with the next best record or all the tie breakers they have. So you have eight teams that come out of the pool play and then you'll play a bracket. So it's three games and if you make it to the final four, then we go to Vegas and they play two games there. Do those games count for the regular season as well? So the final four game does. The championship game is essentially the 83rd game of the season, so that doesn't count
towards the regular season. But if you play in that game and you win the NBA, like the financial incentive is 500,000 for each player. And for the championship. So you have to have a degree in math as well. Math and travel and travel planning the justice. I believe that's unbelievable. When's the end of that tournament? The end the first week of December is the like championship week of the NC the NC's in tournaments. So I have the semifinals. Sorry, the quarter finals, semifinals and the championship game. I think it's like December 9th. Don't call that. But it's the first week of December. And so basically they have the cool part is they, they redesigned courts
for this. Oh, yeah. So if you were just having to be scrolling TV, it's like, you know, you used to watch the on Boise State football games, with that blue field. That blue field. They did that with ours. So they kind of, you know, circused out the courts to make it look and feel way different. Was the box was the bucks. Nick's last night.
Was that in. Oh, every game that was on. So I think it's every Tuesday and Friday are the in season tournament games. And so yeah, you'll see that you'll know you'll like what the hell is going on on the court right here. So it'll stop you. Okay. No, here's I like going to lie. I like to go in a live basketball games. I think it's fun. Okay. Well, we got the quote Listener, you can reach Sean at 310 that's a bubbers ticker if you have an extra take are you looking for a single or a sky? I want to go to
What do you like a box? What do you looking for a single or a guy you want to go to? Or do you want to, what do you like a box? What do you like? What kind of fan experience do you want, Sean? Hey, let me ask, I need to know this because I've often wondered this. Some of the guys who play, who you've known and played with over the year, a lot of them are extremely tall. And we're talking guys who are, and so they go through life as these incredible, they're not just sort of 6465. They're like 696107 feet.
I imagine do they have to just live like freaks? I mean, do they have to have longer beds? What do they do with their cars? What are they with their clothes with their houses? Do they have to have special planes? They're planes. They're always under that. Yeah, yeah, yeah. It's a process.
Like our whole road hotel's a lot of them complain about the feet hanging over the end. There's nothing you can really do about that. I know they probably can't just go to your standard malls and go shop off the racks. They gotta have all the special tailoring and stuff. And it seems like a headache of just having to go and extra step or two for stuff like that.
They're not eligible to drive certain cars, especially if they're in the market. Yeah, I just think about some high luxury type stuff where they actually got to think about legroom and all that. Many vans. So that's it. Yeah, straight up. And you see, like, Shaq is the one
who's had all his cars like custom made for him. Where they like put the seat really. I know Shaq a little bit over the years. He's such an awesome dude. He's a hilarious dude. And one time I was with my kids, I was in Los Angeles. And this dude pulls up in this, in this black car. And the passenger rolls down the window and goes, somebody wants to say hello.
And I was like, oh, okay. And I looked in and I had to keep looking back through the window and shack and move his seat was obviously custom. Like it was in the back seat, basically. We've seen, I think he did a, I think he did a, what's up, big man? He did a crib's video where he went to his bedroom here. Like this, I think it was a core vet if I'm not mistaken,
but it was like a, not a Cali King. It's probably like double the size of that. And he takes it to the extreme, but I know all these guys have to really kind of take into consideration. Speaking of tall players, we've got a brand new one this year, this rookie phenom Victor Wembenyama. Have you played with him yet? Played a preseason game against him. He's seven four and he plays like me. Yeah, right. Yes. He moves. I mean, how, how is it? First of all, let's not say plays like you yet. Let's give him a little bit of time.
I mean, guys, it's got a pretty good J on him. He is, but I mean, I'm talking about consistency over time. He is the, he's the markers. He's like, I do like these, these dribbling drills where you use two basketballs and it's usually like a guard thing is we have the skill set and the hand out. He can do that. He can there's a video of him. You can look it up. Victor Wimbaiyamba
two ball dribbling when I saw it. It's just those smooth and fluid is like what am I actually looking at right now Kevin Durant would would be the closest comparison as far as agility and size and shooting. Yeah. Yeah, but then you see a side by side picture of what 7, 4 versus 6, 10, 6, 11 looks like. And you know, that's this different ball. Are they playing him? I've only seen one game, I think. Do they play him at center? Or do they play him at forward?
Because his size, I mean, so skinny, like, wouldn't he get beat up as a center? Like, would you play him forward? Greg Pave I would not go step in on his His expertise, but I would say if he's a match or a problem No matter who what position you play him at, but they also put some some beef around him and play him like at the two three Yeah, the extended guard in small four position just to make it even more difficult to figure them out. So I saw him playing against Derand once. I saw him playing against Derand the other night and why I watched the highlights and it
was sick just watching all the different shots that he had, all the different things, the block shots, the moves that he had. I was like, it was, yeah, it's like you're like, what, like you said, what am I watching? I've never seen anything like that before. that he had, I was like, it was, yeah, it's like you're like, what, like you said, what am I watching? I've never seen anything like that before. Like, I like the Kevin Durant reference because he was, he's the most pure score at that, that height where he can literally do everything with a ball. But this guy is, they're any, are there any other players in the league right now that,
that, that strike you as, as a kind of unique right now? Like, are you sensing in any sort of new styles of playing that are coming into the league at all that are exciting to you? The interesting thing is, they always said I ruined the game. And by that, obviously, just everybody wants to shoot threes
and see how far deep they can shoot. I mean, you routinely put it, I mean, Sean, this guy shoots front, there's a three point line which they give you an extra point because beyond this line, you know, it's just too far away. So that's where they give you an extra point. He shoots from the four point line. I tell you, Sean, they played in a arena.
They played in a arena. Sean, it's a ball going in the hoop. Where? Is it like, prove it? I'll size it near my house. There's organs playing at most arenas too. You love the area. Yeah, and tank tops are all playing in tanks.
Organs. What do you, one day you look up there, I'm just like up there playing the show. And if you end up as an arena organist, what do you mean? And up. Wait, I want to know something. No, no, no, no, but before, yeah, style of play that you see coming into the league at all. It's just like positionless basketball where everybody can do everything.
It's kind of cool because that's the influence of, you know, them seeing my style and the warrior style over the course of the last decade where you have guys who were good into the locker room now and I have a locker mate who sits to the right of me. Brandon Pajewski, who's just turned 21 or about to turn 21. And so he was in when we won our first championship in 2015, he was in the sixth grade. Oh boy. And so you kind of see the influence of our, he's watching this and now, okay, I'm gonna work on this. I'm gonna try to add that to my game now.
So you just see that infused into the entire league where there's just so many guys that are pretty versatile to do pretty much everything. And you asked the question about what position did this Victor Wimba and I'm gonna play it. Everybody plays every position now. And it's kind of cool to kind of see the mix and the match and the rotations there. Cause there's no, there's no stiffs that just are out there just to set screens and do
nothing else. It's, you gotta be able to be pretty skilled at everything. Yeah. Sean, ask him what his pregame rituals are. Well, I want to know that. Actually, do you want to know that? And his favorite city to play in. And I do want to know that. Sean specials.
And then I also want to know a deeper question, which is with all of your success and how phenomenal you are and the talent that you have been given and you're very young still, you're 35, you said. Mm-hmm. You're so young, you could probably do this for many, many more years. But do you ever think about when you're by yourself and think about gosh, with all of my injuries and all this stuff, like I want to set a clock myself
before my body tells me the clock. Like before, I want to think about this on my terms. Like do I have five years left to have 12 years left? Like what is the span of somebody like you in the field that you're in? And you can hear that in Visaline, right stuff, right? Can you really hear it? Can you really hear it? Less is hard.
He's trying so hard. Making use of the time. I think that's a great question then, because I've started to think about that obviously a little bit more as of late, because you know, there's less years in front of you than there were behind you. And going out on your own terms is kind of the goal. For us, my problem is, I don't know how long I can extend it because I really feel like I'm playing the best basketball of my life now at 35.
When you mix in the experience and reps and wisdom and then know how even balance and on court off course though. But then to your question, I know I'm not going to do it forever. So I talked to Tom Brady about it, named drop. And I feel like he was just saying, you can think about that and you can prepare for what the downturn looks like, but you kind of take it in two year windows. So it's like, what am I doing now that's going to prepare me
for even just getting through next season? Yeah. And then you just wash or repeat that until you wake up one day and you realize, one, I talked about earlier, the joy of the game and making sure that's always there and being able to meet the moment of the competitive energy that you need to have. But then also, yeah, am I really spending eight hours every off day just to get ready
for the next day? Right. Like there's got to be some of them. And I love that Tom Brady is a starly, Tom Brady is a starless, the, no, just kidding. You can always like say, yeah, yeah, no, I mean, I want to play. What's the, what's the sleep regime? How important is it? It's huge.
I was always a joke like once you're getting to later in your prime, I have so many different apps and devices to help me guys sleep. Noise machines. Noise machines, black out goggles, the whole deal. And so it's huge because like that sleep debt is real. It's the only way to really rejuvenate and recover and lie your mind.
You miss home when you're on the road that much? I miss it all the time, but it's where I get the best sleep. And I can't, I'll admit it to y'all. I know this is going out to the world, but it's when I get, see the family. I really miss you guys, but I do look for the road trips. Yeah, because you have to sleep.
Yeah, because you can't better sleep. I know I have my day alone. I do the same thing. And I can't, and I do look for the road trips. Yeah, because you have better sleep. I know I have my day alone. I do the same thing. And I can't, and I feel guilty. I'm in Atlanta right now for a couple weeks. And I feel guilty because I'll send her my partner. She's like, oh, our three year old. Well, I woke up four times, and I'm like,
yeah, and I'm like, do I tell her I had nine hours straight? Because she's so mad. Yeah. She's so happy. This is definitely, well, I want to let you go, because we're our unit an hour. We don't like to keep guests too long, but I want to give you a chance to talk about this incredible philanthropy that you have going as well as your company, unanimous media. I mean, any part of that, you wanna highlight, I mean, there's so much there between underrated golf
and eat, learn, play, and I mean, I don't know how you have time to be so philanthropic and generous and diversified with your production company too. So, yeah. It's, I appreciate that. It's awesome to know the doors, the baths, the walls open and the lanes that, you know, I never thought I'd be able to play in and build and grow
and make impact. And so when you talk about foundation, me and my wife Aisha started a foundation that it's called Eat, Learn, Play. And we are the village for the next generation of young kids, especially in the open community that need the necessary and vital resources to achieve and unlock their full potential.
And so we've been doing that for a little over four years and have- It's $47 million. Yeah, as you've checked that way, I mean, it's incredible. That's a huge community that's come to support. Yeah. And our goal, we cover all operational expenses for the foundation so that every dollar that comes in is 100% is going directly back into the community and now working with the Oakland
Unified School District to hopefully infuse $50 plus million over the next four years into the school system. That's where kids go to eat, learn, and play every single day, and so we're trying to meet them where they are. So we're super excited about that. And even when you come to Inspire's Indexed Interation, you talk about unanimous media, which for us is a unbelievable avenue and venture to continue to elevate storytelling in the way that I can with in the themes of faith, family and sports and you know been on that journey for the last four
years and it's been a part of some amazing projects and truly feel like with with all of the ventures that I have we talked about a hundred ago I feel like I could talk about that for hours, but we're just being able to leverage all the platform that I have that basketball has blessed me with to have something for the next chapter of life when the ball starts going. I love that. I'm giving so much access and opportunity
to both of you. I tell you what, for God's sake, I'm running. Please run for president. You're rich. Nah, I'm kidding. I'm not even kidding. I know, it's me, like this is. I was thinking the same thing. You're the kind of person that we need, man.
I swear to God. At a minimum, see what you can do for the Oakland A's and keep them in town. That's the worst thing. You know, I was trying to keep some inspiration in the bay for sure, but I appreciate that. And just the fact that a basketball is, it's my life has been a part of
You know the ability to to leverage all things we just talked about but you know Hopefully a couple more championships and and then and then what comes next I'll be prepared for then the champions tour I tell you what I'm rooting for the Warriors from this point on Yeah, I'm so I'm so awesome to talk to you. You're such a cool dude. And the thing that you brought so many people, so much joy over the years and entertain them. And then to then take that and continue, you gave a lot of your time. And you obviously got, you were the beneficiary of a lot of things. But to be able to take it and do what you're doing now, man, it's super impressive. Really, really cool.
Yeah, really cool. And it makes me go like, what the fuck is Sean done? Zero. Zero. He's done a fucking is ignoring your offense. No, he's just eating fucking white bread. White bread. White bread.
The fuck? Jesus. Well, cheers to you. Really well done. Keep it going. You got plenty left to give and we can't wait to see it. And I can't wait to see your golf swing in person next time. I gotta see the process of the person too.
I'll tighten it up. I'll come down to LA. I'm down to play with us, man. Absolutely. Well, thank you so much for doing this. I know we were trying for a while. Thanks for making the time. Absolutely.
I appreciate you guys. Obviously, big fans listen to it all the time. So we were trying for a while. Thanks for making the time. Oh, absolutely. I appreciate you guys. Obviously big fans listen to it all the time. So keep doing what you're doing. Okay, thanks, Holly. Good luck, rest of the season. Appreciate you. All right, stay out of the way. Take care.
Bye, buddy. He's amazing. I tried real hard to understand the divisions and then the subdivisions. You know what, Sean, I thought, and I thought, I actually thought, I am gonna show you when I come home. I'll draw it out for you.
I sort of got it and then you go, oh, I actually would be really interested in that. Yeah, yeah, it is, it's very interesting. He is super interesting and cool. Right, yes. Oh my God, Jay, what a solid fellow. Yeah, have you been trying to get him for a while? Like, yeah, you know, he's, you imagine his heart to sort of, you know, when it
works for him, you know, we're flexible. But I mean, he was like traveling. Like, shut up. Yeah. Like, what didn't he say? He's playing tonight. No, it's seven o'clock over there. It's a last day game there or something.
Last night. I forgot that he was that there's a Toronto. Yeah. History is dead. He ended up there. Yeah. And he went to school in a topical. But there's no, it's no wonder he is attached to so many things.
He seems to have got the personality. Like not every sports figure, not every actor, not everybody in the, you know, on the planet has the personality to do with. It seems very, very kind, very genuine, very nice, but I'll bet you $1,000 that Aisha, his wife, is a saint even larger than him. And I'll bet she's driving a lot of this stuff and she probably deserves a huge huge huge. I'm sure, but as you plot, of course,
and as you know, doing stuff, doing what he does at the highest level, requires a lot of energy. And I'm sure got a lot of people pulling at him at different directions because he's got a delivery, he's got a delivery on the court, which is the first thing, right? That's the main, that's how he got to where he is.
And then there's all this other stuff that's part of it. There's the celebrity and there's the main, that's how he got to where he is. And then there's all this other stuff that's part of it. There's the celebrity and there's the foundation and there's the this and there's that. And that's a production coming in. It's like thing. Production. That requires so, each one of those things requires so much energy and time and attention. And to think how, kind of like you said, J.B. about when he plays, how effortlessly he seems to do it. And maybe that betrays like he,
maybe he is, you know, it does have a tougher time managing, but it seems like so balanced as he said. Yeah, it seems very so impressive. Yeah. It's so unbelievably impressive. Yeah. All the stuff that he does at the highest level. Yeah, but that whole thing, like that was a, you know, his whole journey, that's a story.
I was blown away. Bye. Smartness is 100% organic and artisantly handcrafted by Bennett Barbaco, Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Umgurf. Smartness. Our next episode will be out in a week wherever you listen to podcasts, or you can listen to it right now, early on Amazon Music, or early and ad-free by subscribing to Wondry Plus in Apple Podcasts or the Wondry app. Everybody's had them.
Everybody can relate to them. And now, it's time to celebrate them. Bad dates is a wild comedy podcast hosted by me, Jermila Jamil. So each week, my favorite comedian celebrities and funny friends share their epic and true dating nightmares and misfires that they've encountered on the road to love, to shacking, or both. Get ready for some of the funniest, most shocking, and get somehow still deeply relatable stories you will never forget some of the tales that
you are going to hear as long as you live. My guests include the excellent Conan O'Brien, Nikki Glazer, Tignotaro, Bob the Drag Queen, and many more. Plus, you will also be hearing from listeners who share their own date in the past. From the team behind the hip-hop cast Smartless, bad dates will make you laugh a lot, cry a little, and cringe just the right amount. Because as we all know, the worst dates make the best stories. Follow bad dates wherever you get your podcasts.
You can listen early and add free on the Amazon Music or Wondery app. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.